foreign
welcome to the show
thanks guys
um
so
a little bit about my situation uh I
have about 44 000 in student loan debt
um and I'm currently in the the Army
National Guard
um which my contract is ending here next
month and if I spend for another six
years they'll pay off about 15 percent
of that
um student loan debt uh per year I think
over the course of the next
six years of which I think it's taxable
income
and just want to get your thoughts on do
you think it's worth it to extend
um to get the debt paid off or
try and pay that off with my personal or
full-time job
what is your full-time job
uh I do i t auditing
and what does that pay
um I think about 105. oh sweet well
making 105 I I mean is it taking a lot
of your time are you passionate about
the the National Guard stuff or would
you rather just lean into your full-time
job
I I want to lean into my full-time job
but but at the same time you know I'm
going to be getting married here
probably within the next year
um and I want to buy a house
um use my savings towards you know a
payment on that down payment on that
house
um so you know I could pay them off
right now
um but I don't know if it's worth it or
not to stay in I'm not that passionate
about it but here's the deal Nick don't
don't absolutely do not
do not risk the lives of those service
men and women who will rely on you
in the times of great stress and great
fear and great need and in a stressful
response situation just because you have
a six year plan to get your student
loans for given
yeah and and I feel like I'm doing it
just for the money yes
um this is the the stakes are too high
for you to do something this important
in this
um
this dangerous quite frankly just for
the money
one of my closest friends and colleagues
in the world she is um in the National
Guard she does amazing things but she is
she is fully in she's fully committed
um and it's taken a lot from her and
she's she is service oriented so she
gives it that way if she was in this
just for a like man some cool perks and
over the next sick dude you make too
much money pay your stupid student loans
off and get on with your life
you feel you sound paralyzed by
indecision across the board this isn't
about this job this isn't about do I pay
my student loans off I kind of want to
get married you just don't need to start
making some decisions and start walking
forward some way
I know I just feel like it's like this
weight on my shoulders as you know a lot
of other people do
in the country and it's just the thought
of
like hey you know I'm paying this back
it's
I'd rather use that money towards
something else and did you sign your
name on a piece of paper and you told
somebody whoever they may be if you help
me get through college I'll pay you back
yeah then pay him back
he makes six figures dude and on the
math side I mean they're paying six
grand for the first year that's fifteen
percent of the 44. it's not worth it
when you make 105 to wait six years to
become debt free instead of you taking
control and going I make over a hundred
grand I'm paying this thing off in the
next 12 to 18 months
and that puts your future in your hands
because now we're getting a home a lot
sooner once we become debt free we're
going to build a fully funded emergency
fund of three to six months now we're
starting to save up for the down payment
and now this isn't a six year plan this
could be a three or four year plan
so I think you you know what to do at
this point from uh it's from the heart
issue to the math issue you know what
you got to do
the question is are you going to go
about the business of doing it and
saying I'm done with this debt and I'm
going to handle it myself
okay and listen I can't tell you brother
how many people have called over the
last two and a half years three years
I've been sitting in this chair
waiting for the next student loan
forgiveness thing that was going to come
through
it's been forbearance and a forgiveness
and it's a well they're they're delayed
and now we they're just going to go into
this forbearance with no just pay the
stupid things off
pay them off
quit waiting for somebody to come save
you man let's do it and the day you pay
your last loan off the day you write
that check and hit send
and they come out and they announce
whoever they happens to be we're
forgetting all student loans you'll be
able to sleep at night because you sign
your name on a piece of paper that said
I'll pay you back and you kept your word
to nobody if nobody else but just to you
and you will have proven yourself you're
a person of character move on with your
life
is that fair
yeah I think that's fair be Resolute man
Stand Tall throw your shoulders back put
your head up
I don't think it's worth the other
or the to the other people to stay in
for another six years when I'm not fully
invested I I let me put it this way I
wouldn't want you standing shoulder to
shoulder with me
if you were doing this for an extra 500
a month in student loan forgiveness
I would want somebody who was ready to
jump in front of a bullet for me because
I'm ready to jump in front of a bullet
for you and if that's not where you're
at no that's all good I'm not in the
service obviously
um
then yeah I think you've answered your
own question
okay cool I appreciate all the the
advice you got it man yeah I think the
person who you trust the least right now
is you you just feel indecisive and I
would say take a take a hard step and
also say this George
um there are people I've worked in this
industry for almost two decades there
are people who
signed their name away to things they
had no idea what they're getting into
and there was entire swaths of people
that I think were targeted and tricked
so there's no shame to sit down and say
hey I need help right and
um that's a whole other conversation but
if you're sitting there making six
figures and you're thinking about trying
to take this somewhat risky side gig for
the six years and just pay them off for
God's sake yeah it's not worth the
golden handcuffs at that point when
there's really not that much those are
like yeah those are like uh copper maybe
no they're like pipe cleaner handcuffs
pipe cleaner oh my goodness you know
what I mean they're like not very not
very strong well all of this
conversation reminds me of our
documentary barred future which you were
featured in John because of your
experience in higher ed you brought some
really cool perspective to this whole
thing so I want to encourage anyone
who's in this world you've got student
loans you're thinking about taking them
on please go watch our documentary
borrowed future it's on YouTube it's
free go check it out it'll spark some
amazing conversations from Pair returns
to kids